today general motors joined ford and
toyota in suspending or reducing
production because assembly lines simply
don't have enough auto parts a wrench
thrown into the supply chain this week
by protesting truckers almost two weeks
ago convoys of canadian truckers began
arriving in the capital ottawa to
protest the country's pandemic policies
including a vaccination mandate for
truckers who cross from the u.s into
canada
some pandemic mandates we have to say
are already being lifted in canada but
the truckers they are not leaving
this week's protesters they began
blocking
key border crossings between canada and
the u.s including the economically
important ambassador bridge which
connects detroit in the u.s with windsor
in canada a quarter of all trade between
the two countries crosses this bridge
300 million dollars every day a hundred
million just for the auto industry
day 14 of a protest that has caught the
world's attention
canadian truckers have parked their
vehicles in front of prime minister
justin trudeau's office bringing much of
the capital ottawa to a standstill
originally this was a protest against a
vaccine mandate for truckers who cross
into the u.s
it has since broadened out to the
fringes and is supported by far-right
extremists and conspiracy theorists
well quite honestly i have accepted the
fact that we are the fringe men already
but i'm quite proud to be the fringe
minority
of hundreds of thousands of trucks
and millions of spectators
yeah and do you do you see yourself on
the political spectrum as being the far
right yes
the protests are spreading
overnight demonstrators blocked a bridge
connecting canada to the u.s shutting
down a quarter of cross-border traffic
more than two-thirds of canadians
disapprove of the protests and
frustrated locals have been making their
opinions clear too
well the one about the dogs was pointing
out some of the stupidity of the
protesters
a lot of them brought their dogs put
them to the
protest and the honking is incredibly
dangerous for dogs
it bothers me it
i think it strikes at what
a lot of people feel about what they
feel
canadian values are and we cherish
freedom and this is not about freedom
but with the truckers prepared for the
long haul it might be some time until
ottawa residents get their city back
my first guest tonight is maxine bernier
he's the leader of the people's party of
canada he joins me tonight from montreal
mr bernier it's good to have you with us
i got some statistics yesterday about 90
of canadian truckers are fully
vaccinated against the coronavirus
so explain to us then what is this
protest about
it's about ending all the mandates that
we still have in canada you're right you
know vaccinated truckers or unvaccinated
truckers it's not about that anymore
you know we i cannot as an unvaccinated
canadian travel across this country by
plane uh i cannot go to a restaurant and
you know people are losing their jobs
because they decided not to take the two
shots and the two shots so people are
fed up with that we are looking at other
countries in europe and other states in
the u.s and there's no mandates anymore
the economy is open i understand that it
can be you know it can hurt the economy
in canada but you know the last two
years
we
we shut down the economy and the tridel
government and spend a lot of money that
we don't have big deficit of 500 billion
dollars and we are paying for that right
now with inflation in canada so these
truckers right now represent 30 of the
population that are saying enough is
enough and they want to regain their
freedoms well mr benny i think we can
all relate to the the pandemic fatigue
that the truckers are experiencing i
experience it i'm sure you do
as well but
we can't change the reality that the
pandemic is not over yet i mean
do you think it's right for truckers or
for anybody to to try to use a protest
to end or to get to declare a pandemic
over when it's not really over
yeah yeah but it's not really over but
we know that in canada you know the last
variant oh my crown it's not it's like a
big call and everybody are saying that
right now so
kohit is not that dangerous that it was
in the beginning of that pandemic
and and people understand that that's mr
billy okay kennedy
yeah mr benny i mean we i can't let you
say that it's not just like a cold now
just south of the border
in the united states you have 2700
people dying every day from covet 19.
that's not a cold and i'm sure the
numbers in canada are similar how can
you say that
yeah in 2015 in 2015 in canada more
people died from the cold from the flu
so you know right now that variant it's
it's not so dangerous for people that
don't have any comorbidities and that's
why these truckers have the support of
20 of the population so i hope that all
that will end uh the trudeau government
has the solution they can just stop all
these mandates and everything will be
reopened and everybody will be able to
go back to their lives that's what they
want uh how can you be so sure that are
you are you a medical doctor
no i'm not and you're not also but you
have right to this side and we have the
right to look at the study and that's
what we're doing so you know no but i
mean you're not telling me that but no
mr penny i'm not telling public health
officials or the politicians that they
should lift restrictions i mean i am not
qualified i'm not a scientist i'm not a
doctor um
neither are you
yeah but that's the first time in the
history of the world that we shut down
the economy and do lockdowns and stay at
home borders and curfew to fight a virus
that's not working and we know that we
have two years of data right now so that
virus is dangerous and deadly for older
people with comorbidities so let's
protect the most vulnerable in our
society and reopen the society that's
what we want like you know canada under
oath
countries in europe yeah mr bernie is is
is canada under a lockdown at the moment
no we are not but we were and now you
are the best
and segregation in our country
in our country between between
vaccinated people and unvaccinated
people we are losing our rights and our
freedoms and people
vaccinated one and on vaccinated one
want that to end i was in ottawa last
weekend and i spoke with people and you
have vaccinated people over there that
are not saying enough is enough we need
to
we need to respect everybody and the
choice of everybody mr bernier yesterday
on twitter we've got a tweet that you
posted we want to pull that up for our
viewers you tweeted here's an idea fine
or jail all public health officials and
politicians responsible for destroying
our fundamental rights and freedoms over
the past two years
now mr bennie do you honestly believe
that canadian public officials public
health officials
have done anything these last two years
other than trying to save and protect as
many lives as possible
yes so that tweet was a tweet and
respond in another tweet that a lady
said we must buy and put in jail all
people that decided not to have the
vaccine so when i tweeted about that i
was that was not serious about that as
you may know so you you you're recording
that tweet all
out of context first second yes they did
their best but when we have the data
right now and we have the data for the
last year we needed to protect the most
vulnerable we didn't do that 80 percent
of our debts in canada are people older
than 70 years old and they were under
the responsibility of the federal
government because the federal
government is responsible for mister of
uh giving yeah i mean listen i i think
all of us will agree that in the last
two years we've we've seen our public
health officials you know they didn't
get it right every time i mean this is a
new virus
they were
learning lots of times while doing um
but the motive is what matters here the
motive from our public health officials
be it in canada the us or here in
germany um has always been at least
that's the way i see it is to protect as
many lives as possible
what what can you have against that
i have against that we are still under
state emergency in some provinces in
canada and there's no emergency anymore
and these establishment politicians are
using the state emergency to impose
draconian measures like you know a
vaccine passport
for for being able to participate in our
society that's unfair that's unjust
that's unconstitutional
well you do you know that some of the
restrictions are being lifted across
parts of canada they have this week as a
matter of fact
um yes
yes you absolutely right
in the province of saskatchewan they
said no more vaccine passport no more
vaccine mandates in saskatchewan
february in alberta they'll do the same
thing in my own province in quebec the
premier of quebec said he will keep the
vaccine passport so that's the same
situation in every province i agree with
that mr benny why not though rely on you
on the doctors the scientists the public
health officials in canada who are
monitoring the numbers the infection
rates why not rely on them to give the
all clear to lift restrictions to lift
the restrictions when it is safe what is
the problem with that
because they told us that the vaccine
cannot stop the transmission of the
virus everybody can catch and spread
that virus so why doing discrimination
between vaccinated people and
unvaccinated people that that's based on
science we understand that the vaccine
is very good to be able to for older
people or young people that want to be
safe and being sure that they won't have
uh they won't have severe coved and i
agree with that so but everybody must be
free to decide and that's not the case
the polls show the polls show that a
majority of canadians first of all
canada has one of the highest
vaccination rates in the world a poll
shows the latest quote shows that a
majority of canadians are in favor of
penalizing people who break the pandemic
restrictions at the moment you're not
speaking for the majority of canadians
aren't you just trying to protest your
way to break the pandemic rules
no and i'm not proud of that some
canadians said you know that we must put
in jail people that decided not to be
vaccinated i'm not proud of that but you
know in the beginning of january only 10
of the population were saying you know
we have proved that we must end all
these mandates and now that 10 percent
is at 32
more people are fed up with that and we
must end that there's no reason to be
under an emergency state in canada
anymore well maxine bernier leader of
the people's party of canada mr bernie
we appreciate you taking the time to
speak with us tonight we certainly wish
all canadians the very best thank you
i appreciate that thank you have a nice
day
you